if television reduces life to inches  motion pictures enlarge it to yards and  I dare say that the five men we  nominated are themselves larger than  life because they're actors I know I  married one  and the Oscar goes to Jeremy I am  this is great thank you the Academy and  thank you everybody whose wish me well  for this specifically Thank You Warner  Brothers sovereign pictures edy Pressman  Barbra Schroeder  Luciana tahvalli our lighting cameraman  people who made me look like that  Alan why zinger and Dick Smith thank you  my co-stars Ron silver and Glen for  finally persuading me to do it thank you  Fred Spector Ann Hutton Sally Fisher  thank you also in some of you may  understand why thank you David  Cronenberg and lastly if I may cut the  call of a telephone to London where my  wife is trying to keep a wait and awake  in a hotel bedroom I wish you were here  to help me carry this because you helped  me win it thank you all  you